et nous voici dans les débuts de l'inria
il ya ces anciens objets sont les
ancêtres de l'informatique
l'institut national de recherche en
sciences du numérique plus communément
appelée inria à accompagner son
développement en france depuis plus de
50 ans à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir une exposition qui retrace
l'histoire de ce lieu emblématique de
l'informatique
on est passé de l'ordinateur de bureau
au travail en réseau etc
maintenant tout le monde est connecté et
caetera et je pense que cette exposition
elle montre le cheminement vers l'état
actuel des choses c'est la deuxième fois
que l'inria ouvre ses portes lors des
journées du patrimoine
deux cents personnes travaillent
aujourd'hui sur ce site créé en 1952 par
les troupes alliées
cette croix de l'otan encore visibles
sur le domaine témoigne de ce passé nous
avons vraiment la chance sur ce domaine
historique d'avoir des vestiges de
l'après-guerre qui préfigurait ce
qu'elle est finalement de venir
le site par la suite avec un haut lieu
de l'histoire de l'informatique et inria
aujourd'hui le site de rocquencourt
ouvrira ses portes au public le samedi
21 septembre
l'occasion notamment pour le jeune
public de comprendre comment on faisait
avant